tout d'abord notre page et et qui nous
permet de vivre à distance le festival
l'écho du cac thouars à cheverny marine
rando nier et pierre dominique loupé son
surplace alors marine le coup d'envoi du
festival a été donné cet après midi mais
les festivités avaient commencé un petit
peu plus tôt il ya un festival off
et oui en effet c'est un festival off
très particulier puisqu'il se déroule
chaque année avant le début du festival
à la maison de retraite de cour cheverny
dans quelques mètres avant d'arriver à
cheverny volaille et maisons de retraite
qui s'appelle la favorite et nous y
étions vous allez voir il ya eu un
spectacle de rue mais il ya aussi eu un
petit spectacle des enfants donc je vous
laisse regarder on se retrouve juste
après bleu autour d'olivier courtemanche
comédiens professionnels des enfants du
centre de loisirs de contre le thème de
leur spectacle deux pays en compétition
pour présenter les meilleures inventions
en hommage à leonard de vinci depuis
mercredi trois heures par jour
il répète avec le comédien qui a voulu
leur transmettre le plaisir de jouer
pour les enfants général et savent jouer
alors faut rajouter quelques règles et
surtout l'idée du public d'un public
on joue pour un public c'est ce que je
leur dis à cette fois il parle beaucoup
c'est ce que je leur dis on va faire un
cadeau jouer une un spectacle c'est
faire un cadeau au public après les
enfants c'est au tour des pros
combien mesure ils vont en temps normal
le mètre soixante dix les camps je
m'éloigne il m'arrive d'être un peu plus
au faut préciser je dirais lui m case la
compagnie soliloque a spécialement créé
la joconde avait-elle froid aux pieds
pour le festival de cheverny la joconde
chausset du 36 au tour de taille le
public
les résidents de la maison de retraite
de cour cheverny qui ont chacun ait
droit à un spectacle en avant première
du festival
la plus grande largeur des épaules est
contenue dans le cas d'un homme
oui c'est une découverte est un
spectacle qui n'auraient pas forcément
eu l'occasion d'aller voir ou de voir
donc
c'est ce qu'ont été découvertes et voilà
j'ai un petit peu de jeunesse aussi les
casques
on a la fierté de d'entendre ça commence
quand ils reviennent quand des artistes
des comédiens
donc on sait que les gens qui attendent
bien évidemment c'est une démarche est
bien évidemment on n'a pas le retour
direct non en quoi quel que soit de
retour on est tout à fait content de
participer et d'apporter cette petite
lumière peut-être mystique dans des
lieux comme celui-ci quoi qui sont
forcément quelques prêtres peuvent
visiter peu partagé pendant 1h30 les
résidents de la maison de retraite sont
un peu sortis de leur quotidien
la compagnie soliloque jorat dans les
rues de cheverny demain en fin d'après
midi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien vous la reconnaissez peut-être
était-elle bezeau qui joue vide dans le
spectacle qu'on vient de voir bonsoir
bonsoir
alors dites moi quel est votre ressenti
là après avoir joué dans ce lieu un peu
particulier mais très très heureux et
puis si une chouette expérience de
pouvoir jouer pour un public de
personnes âgées qui était assez curieuse
de nous découvrir
et puis le mélange aussi entre y avait
des deux jeunes enfants aussi qu'ils
étaient là donc intéressant de voir les
réactions selon si on a des oreilles
d'enfants ou de grands-parents moi c'est
un spectacle où vous avez créé
spécialement pour le festival l'écho du
cas que toi
voilà exactement c'est la mairie de
cheverny qui nous a passé une petite
commande donc pour faire une petite
forme de rue
en prenant appui sur léonard de vinci et
de là est née la joconde avait-elle
froid aux pieds c'est le titre du
spectacle
donc on s'est appuyé sur sur cette
question en fait qui nous est sorti
comme ça au tout début la joconde
avait-elle froid au pied et ensuite on a
écrit toute une liste de questions tout
assez singulière est absurde de type la
joconde avait-elle froid aux pieds
si les oiseaux n'existait pas l'homme
aurait t'il songer à voler quand l'homme
tombe
comment faire pour qu'il tombe du bon
côté voilà et on tente de répondre à ces
questions et bien merci beaucoup est l
on vous retrouve je crois demain puisque
vous allez déambuler en ville
20la à partir de 15h très bien 15 heures
donc le rendez vous est donné
et puis nous ce soir on va voir web
mercato sur la scène juste à côté puis
on vous montre tout ça demain midi